in an unusual publication called the
patriot post a bodybuilder and
meteorologists named Joe Bastardi
challenged me he challenged me to show a
connection between carbon dioxide and
the atmosphere in the world's
temperature and he challenged me to make
a forecast a prediction well mister
Bastardi you're a meteorologist a
weatherman so let's do this weatherman
style in his article mister Bastardi
presents this graph it shows the world's
temperature and the world's carbon
dioxide over the last four and a half
billion years these curves have to be
based on computer models the world's
continents were not where they are today
there were no living things producing
oxygen and the sun's brightness was
different than it is now but if we look
over here we have real data and you can
see that the world is getting warmer
these five curves were produced by five
independent organizations and they all
got the same answer now in his article
mister Bastardi presented a second graph
which started over here around 2005-2006
when there was an El Nino so if you
start when it's warm of course it's
going to go down a little bit at first
I'm not sure why you would choose to
present the graph this way I can't help
but think about Upton Sinclair who said
it's hard to get a man to believe
something when his salary depends on his
not believing it mister Bastardi I
cannot help but note that you've spoken
at the coal trading conference Nebraska
propane in the gas forum where you speak
is your business but it also seems to be
your business telling your audiences
what they want to hear but all this
aside let's talk about the forecast my
prediction
so mr. Bastardi I will bet you $10,000 I
predict that the year 2016 will be among
the top ten hottest years ever recorded
this cheque could be yours if you take
the bet and it turns out not to be among
the top ten hottest years but if it does
and you take the bet you would owe me
ten
thousand dollars wait I'll take it up a
notch I'll bet you another $10,000 that
the decade 2010 to 2020 will prove to be
the hottest decade ever recorded so
that's two bets of $10,000 that that you
could win if you believe that the world
is for some reason getting cooler
instead of hotter so come on champ show
us how tough you are